but I saw it on the televisions
afternoon I listened very carefully to
her statements and I've since read a
copy of it and of course I'm very happy
to meet her we need to have a discussion
with the Prime Minister we need to
ensure that Parliament has an
opportunity to vote on proposals that
prevent us crashing out of the EU in the
end of next week and we also need to
ensure that we give security
uncertainties the people of this country
that there will not be a crashing out at
the end of this process what will your
negotiating position be when you meet
the Prime Minister what will you be
demanding of her we put forward our
proposals which are to ensure there is a
customs union with the European Union
that there is access to those markets
and above all those protections of our
standards of consumer environmental and
of course workers rights and will ensure
that those are there on the table
so that there is no danger of crashing
out but we're also very clear that there
has to be an absolute guarantee that the
Good Friday Agreement maintains so we
continue with the process of peace in
Northern Ireland
this is or could be a fairly major
compromise from the Prime Minister are
you willing to compromise on Labour's
red lines but so far she hasn't shown
that kind of compromise but I'm pleased
that today she is indicated she will
accept a view of Parliament and is
prepared to reach out and have that
discussion our basis is about protecting
jobs protecting living standards and
ensuring that our trade continues in the
future and that we don't become some
kind of deregulated offshore tax haven
on the shores of Europe it is about
supporting people and their jobs but
it's also about the kind of country
around the future one that's going to be
investing in the future of our people
one is going to be guaranteeing higher
living standards and better wages but
would you be willing to me the Prime
Minister somewhere in the middle perhaps
around the customs union a simpler
solution rather than the extra
guarantees that you want we voted for a
customs union in the house yesterday it
narrowly lost we understand the
importance of it because that helps to
maintain trade we will meet the Prime
Minister we recognise that she has made
I recognize my responsibility to
represent the people that supported
labour in the last election and the
people who didn't support labour but
nevertheless want certainty and security
for their own future and that's the
basis on which we will meet her and
we'll have those discussions and
proposals will be put to Parliament to
understand early next week so that we
can avoid crashing out at the end of
next week and we can guarantee the
protection of those jobs and that trade
in the future so it sounds as if you are
in a compromising mood potentially I
have been meeting MPs from all parties
over the last couple of weeks long
discussions with a lot of colleagues and
it's been very interesting process and
yes there is some common ground there
are some areas that it's very difficult
to agree on but the principles have to
be as I've set out that however people
voted in the referendum in 2016
whether they voted remain or they voted
leave they didn't vote for lower living
standards they didn't vote to lose their
jobs and actually there's far more that
unites people on both sides about the
kind of society we can be then divides
them do you agree with the Prime
Minister that it's important that
Britain does not take part in the
European elections next month
well it looks as though that may not be
the we may not be taking part in those
elections I don't see that as the most
important issue one way or the other the
most important issue is to make sure we
don't crash out of the of the EU next
week with no deal and what I believe
will be a degree of chaos that follow as
a result of it it's one last one last
I'm not compromising then in that case
would so are you saying that you are
willing to compromise on your red lines
if it means avoiding that crash out
which you believe would be so
detrimental we will discuss with the
prime minister I don't want to set any
limits one way or the other
ahead of those meetings I want you to
understand the principles on which I
will go into those meeting recognising
the needs of the people that have
elected all MPs to Parliament and the
need to avoid a dangerous crashing out
just lastly given that you will now be
in negotiations with the Prime Minister
does that mean we can expect you not to
bring a vote
no confidence in the government and
extra police we hold in reserve and our
right to bring a motion of no confidence
in the government if the government
proves its incapable of commanding a
majority in the House of Commons time
will tell on that but our
responsibilities the opposition is to
make sure that we don't crash out and is
I believe to make sure that we have a
government does command a majority in
the house and does indeed command
support majority support across the
country at the moment we don't have that